la fin de la visite de nicolas sarkozy
en syrie c'est le président de la
république a salué les gestes de bonne
volonté de damas jusqu'où bachar
el-assad est il prêt à aller pour
réintégrer la syrie dans le concert des
nations nous lui poserons la question
dans un instant il est notre invité
d'abord le bilan de cette visite avec
renaud bernard et francis forget
la conversation a l'air cordiale
pourtant entre nicolas sarkozy et son
hôte syrien il y à l'ombre du nucléaire
iranien qui plane et nicolas sarkozy
compte sur bachar al assad pour
convaincre l'iran de renoncer à
construire la bombe atomique
je pense que la syrie peut avoir une
influence et comme l'iran perdre
beaucoup de temps trop de temps et que
nous voulons la paix on doit utiliser
tous les canaux pour convaincre l'iran
de ne pas se laisser aller cette
stratégie qui serait très mauvaise de
penser que le temps travaille pour eux
ça ne marche pas bachar al assad
n'entend pas jouer les médiateurs il
reste l'allié de l'iran pour lui les
activités nucléaires de téhéran sont
purement civiles
l'autre enjeu du sommet les pourparlers
entre la syrie et israël les deux pays
sont ennemis l'occupation du plateau du
golan par l'armée israélienne dure
depuis 41 ans pour le moment damas et
tel aviv échangent leurs points de vue
par l'intermédiaire de la turquie
l'enjeu désormais parvenir à des
négociations directes le premier
ministre turc joue un rôle extrêmement
important dans les négociations pour
l'instant indirectes entre israël et la
syrie et sont indirectes pour passer
mieux quand il n'avait pas ce soir pour
le président syrien engager des
discussions directes avec son ennemi
israélien
c'est prématuré
voilà et ont dû